هذا الصباح يمكننا أن نظهر لك هذا الأمر ،
وعلينا توخي الحذر نظرًا
لمقبض تويتر للشخص الذي
أرسله في المقام الأول ، حيث أعاد
رئيس الولايات المتحدة ، رئيس
الولايات المتحدة ، إعادة تغريد مقطع فيديو على
Twitter يظهره وهو يضرب كرة غولف
ثم كرة الجولف تضرب
هيلاري كلينتون
وتسقطها أرضًا ، ترى ذلك هناك ، أعاد رئيس الولايات المتحدة تغريده هذا
الصباح لماذا ما قاله السيد السيئ
الذي تعرفه تقليديًا
يتحدث عن عطلات نهاية الأسبوع في بيدمينستر حتى في
وقت مهم مثل عطلة نهاية الأسبوع عندما يكون
الذهاب إلى الجمعية العامة للأمم المتحدة
لأول مرة
كرئيس للولايات المتحدة في أوقات محفوفة بالمخاطر
ربما يكون بمفرده ،
وربما لا يكون محاطًا بالعديد من المساعدين
مثلك كما هو الحال في العادة بالتأكيد ليس في
هذه الساعة من الصباح على ما أعتقد
تعرف التيارات بشكل صحيح ، إنه معطل كما
تعلم ولديه هذه الدوافع التي يستمتع
بالتفاعل معها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
تسمعه يتحدث عن ذلك  هذا مهم
جدًا لهويته ويريد الناس أن يسمعوا
منه ، لكن من غير المعتاد
الخروج في الأسبوعين الماضيين من عدم العثور
على الكلمات المثيرة للاهتمام لأنه الرئيس يقول إنه
مجنون للغاية وهو الكلمة مرة أخرى
إنه يحب العناوين الرئيسية عندما يتعامل
مع الديمقراطيين عندما يُنظر إليه على أنه
ينجز الأمور عندما يُرى كما تعلم وهو
يفي بالوعود ، ولكن بعد ذلك
سيخرج صباح يوم السبت
ويفجر نفسه
بهذه التغريدات المجنونة  ليسوا رئاسيين ،
إنهم لا يرسلون أي أجندة معينة
له ، أعني أن هذا لم يكن
متعلقًا بالهجرة ، ولم يكن يتعلق بأي شيء يتعلق بالسياسة ،
إنه مجرد شيء ربما
كان يعتقد أنه مضحك